One movie takes $ 10.50 for a ticket
and 5 dollars for a basket of popcorn.
You never buy popcorn because you think,
that they are too expensive.
Is the total price you pay just proportional to the number
of the tickets you buy?
This is interesting because we are told the price
a basket of popcorn, but we are also told,
that we never buy popcorn.
I do not know why we've ever been told
what is the price; perhaps, to confuse us.
The total price you pay is straightforward
Is it the number of tickets you buy?
Okay, you only buy tickets;
you will not buy any popcorn,
so you will spend $ 10.50 on each ticket.
This should be straightforward.
But to see it a little clearer,
let me draw a small table here.
So the number of tickets;
and then price, total price.
We assume that I never buy popcorn.
If I buy a ticket, the price will be 10.50.
If I buy 2 tickets, she will be 2 at 10.50
or $ 21.00.
If I buy 3 tickets, we'll have 3 at 10.50.
Which is how much?
31.50.
You see the relationship between the price
and the number of tickets
will always be 10.50.
10.50 divided by 1;
21 divided by 2;
31.50 divided by 3;
always 10.50.
This is because the price, in other words,
the price will simply be 10.50
by the number of tickets.
It is clear that we have a direct relationship.